In this video, we'll start looking at how we can create assets like levels, static meshes, and materials inside of Unreal Engine.
Okay, so now let's look at creating a new level inside of Unreal Engine.
So similar to Unity, we can go up to the File menu, and instead of hitting New Scene, we can hit New Level.
This will open up a couple of templates that we can pick from.
Select Open World.
Additionally, we can right-click in the content drawer and create a new level from here.
Next, we'll create an actor, as opposed to Unity, which has the new Game Object button as part of the hierarchy.
Over in Unreal Engine, we have the new Actor button as part of the toolbar.
Here, I will go to Shapes and Cube and drag it into my level.
I can also press F to hone in on it and see it down here.
We can see that this cube has a transform and a static mesh component and a material component.
This is going to be very similar to a game object inside of Unity that has a transform component, a mesh filter, a mesh renderer, and a box collider, as well as a rigid body.
Next, we're going to add a component to our new actor.
This would be very similar to how we would do it in Unity, where we hit this Add Component button and select from our list of components.
In Unreal, we can select our cube and hit the Add Component button up here at the top.
In this case, I'm going to look for a rotating movement component.
Take off that one.
I think this is another one.
One thing to note here, if we want this static mesh to actually be able to move, we have to set it to movable here.
This is important for how Unreal Engine allocates objects for rendering so that movable objects can be rendered together and static objects can be rendered together.
Now, when we press Play, we can see our lovely box spinning in place for us.
Now, let's move on to creating a Blueprint.
This is how we're going to be able to add interactivity back to our content.
Entire games can actually be made using Blueprint visual scripting without even touching C++.
So, back over here in Unreal, I can right-click, create a Blueprint class.
We're going to pick an actor, and I will call this BP underscore spin cube.
We'll open this up. We see our Blueprint editor.
We see our default scene route.
And let's go ahead and add a static mesh component.
This has a transform, and we can assign a static mesh here.
We will look for cube.
We'll hit compile.
If we zoom out, there's our cube here.
We have a default material for now.
And then we see a couple tabs up here.
We have the construction tab that we won't look at, this construction graph, and our event graph.
So, instead of needing to write a C sharp component over here in Unity and add...
Let's see, we have an axis rotation component that I've written that will allow us to spin around our cube here in Unity.
Back over in Unreal, if we want to do the same thing,
once again, I can add my rotating movement component.
I can drag that into the graph to get a reference to it.
And I can get the pull-off from this pin here,
and this will bring up all of the different properties that we might want to look for
using the rotating movement component.
I'm going to get its rotation rate.
Let's see, there we go, get rotation rate.
I want to multiply this by negative one.
And then I want to set the rotation rate.
And so what this is going to allow me to do is change the direction that the cube is spinning in.
However, right now, these nodes here will never run
because they aren't hooked up to an event that will trigger them.
So, I'm going to delete both of these to give myself a little more room.
I'm going to search for the space bar.
We'll drag that up here, drag this back over, get ourselves a little more organized here.
And now, when we press the space bar, we are going to set our rotation rate.
However, if we try to do this immediately right now,
let's see if we drag in our spin cube.
Ooh, it's a little bit bigger, isn't it?
And we hit play.
We'll see that it spins, but when we hit space bar, nothing happens except for our character moving up.
Why is that?
So, how do we enable input?
Well, why don't we search for that?
Enable input.
And one thing we need for this to work here is a reference to the player controller.
We'll talk about this a little bit more when we go into the gameplay framework inside of Unreal Engine.
But now, I'm going to hit compile this.
We should see, we go to test, our cube is spinning, and we press space, and it turns the other way.
Amazing.
One more thing that we can do here in order to make our code a little more reusable
is what if we one day wanted to call this logic without pressing the space bar?
Well, in order to do that, we would need to create our own custom event
to switch direction and have our logic to change the rotation direction
listen for that instead.
Now, our space bar can call switch direction.
We'll save this again here. We'll compile this up here.
So, similar to when you save a C Sharp script and it compiles before you can add it to your game objects.
This is after we make changes. We want Unreal Engine to compile our blueprint code.
I'll save it as well.
And now, just to double check that it works, press space, and it spins around.
Okay, so now we'll start to change the look of our actors, and we'll do that by creating a material.
This is a look at the material graph, which looks a lot like the blueprint editor's graph.
We'll be dropping nodes onto here and using that to create logic that will affect the rendering properties of our material.
So, we can get started by right-clicking, creating material, and I'll call this M underscore cube.
And if you want to see how to more consistently name your assets throughout your project and across projects,
I would recommend checking out the Michael Auer style guide.
This is a wide array of generally accepted nomenclature.
So, when you start working with more developers or looking at other people's projects,
you'll be able to better understand what's inside of them.
So, here we have our basic output mode that's on the surface material domain and has a blend mode of opaque.
And with the default lit shading model, we won't worry too much about all that.
What we want to do is add a constant vector three.
So, if you don't know, this vector can also be a color representation.
So, I'm going to pick a color that I like, this color purple.
Okay, and we can drag that into the base color output, and we'll see our preview over here start to change.
And I'll drag it into the emissive color output.
And now it's starting to glow.
We'll hit apply. This is very similar to the compile button inside of a blueprint editor.
And then now over here in our level, we can drag our material onto, where's our static mesh?
There we go. And we'll see when we pick up the material to drag it in,
it highlights the area that it is applicable or possible to be dragged into.
And there we go. We've got our new material on our cube.
One thing we'll notice, we have a little asterisk here next to our level.
That means we aren't saved.
So, let's go ahead and click save.
And I'll call this one map session level.
And I'll save that here in the session content folder.
There we go. Awesome.
Now when we press play, we can see our material in action.
So, the next thing we're going to make is a material instance.
This is a great thing to get your head around early in your Unreal development journey.
Material instances are a way to take a single material asset
and make it more extendable and reusable
and reduce your total memory footprint of assets inside of your game.
So, what we can do by setting up our base material
that we just created with different parameters
is that we can then edit those parameters
in different instances of that material.
This gives us a lot more flexibility
and then reduces our memory footprint
and lets our game run better.
So, how are we going to do that?
Back over here in Unreal, we can right click on our material
and right up here at the top we see create material instance.
The nomenclature for this one is going to be MI
and we can open this up.
And so far we see we've got some parameters here
but nothing that we can change for our color.
So, how can we do that?
Well, if we come back over to our base material
and we right click, we'll see this option to convert to parameter.
This gives us an opportunity to name it
and then we also see it appear over here in the details panel.
Hit apply, save it too just for good measure
and now here in our material instance
we see that we have a global vector parameter for color
that we can override and make this one a fun green color for instance.
We'll hit save, go back to our session level,
select our cube instance and we can drag our material instance
into our cube and now we have two different cubes
but they both share the same core asset for their material.
In Unity, this direct relationship between a material
and a material instance doesn't exist in separate assets.
Although you can instance objects that have the same material on them
and so we just saw this over in editor
but after you've created a material instance
you can assign it in the material slot of a static mesh
the same way you can with a master or base material
and it should be noted that you should really try and rely on this workflow
as much as you can in order to reduce the total amount of memory
that your project takes up and game takes up.
In the next video, we'll look at how we can add content
to our Unreal Engine project and then use it in our levels.